so I want to start by thanking the
organizers for the opportunity to speak
today say I'm going to tell you
hopefully quickly about our new approach
for identifying combinations of mutually
exclusive alterations in cancer and so
as we've already heard over the past
kind of day or so when you large-scale
sequencing studies with the last decade
or so have shown that they're relatively
few statistically significantly mutated
genes and in kind of moderately sized
tumor cohorts with a long tail of rarely
mutated genes it was just kind of a
cartoon plot showing you what you might
find in a cohort of 250 to 500 tumor
samples and so kind of this corresponds
with the observation that no two tumors
are alike they have different
combinations of mutations and so one of
the prominent explanations for why there
is kind of long tail phenomenon is that
mutations in cancer target pathways and
so each of these pathways can be mutated
or perturbed in numerous ways and so we
might actually think of this plot a
little differently so we might have a
pair of jeans for example that interact
to perform some function where a it's
just mutated more often so it shows up
as significantly mutated while B is in
the long tail and so this is exactly the
kind of analysis cancer biologists
perform so here I'm showing a figure
from the TCGA colorectal paper and they
group genes into mutated pathways
however this figure was manually
constructed so there's no notion of
statistical significance which raises
the obvious research question can we
discover the pathways and so you know
one idea would be to just enumerate gene
sets and test them for over
representation of mutations however
there are too many gene sets to test and
if we could test them all we would never
be able to choose statistical
significance another idea would be to
look at known pathways or gene sets but
then we be limited in discovering novel
pathways or crosstalk between pathways
and so today we're going to talk about a
different strategy that involves looking
at mutually exclusive mutations and so
to motivate that I have a figure from
Thomas at all showing mutations in the
rtk rat signaling pathway across
different patients so in this matrix we
have genes or low sigh as Rose patients
as columns and each of these marks is
representing a different mutation in a
different sample and so you can see that
the few columns have more than one
marker mutation meaning that the samples
are mutually exclusive mutations across
the pathway and so one of the
explanations for this is that you know
we need to have relatively few driver
mutations responsible for cancer and
they're distributed across multiple
pathways in each patient and so as a
result we have approximately one driver
mutation / pathway per patient and so
over the last five years a number of
different methods have been introduced
for identifying mutually exclusive
mutations and it's a very active field
with you know multiple publications from
last year we're going to talk about our
method the combinations of mutually
exclusive alterations or comment
algorithm which is published last year
in genome biology and is a joint work
with since I woo and so comment includes
a new statistical score that is less
biased towards most frequently mutated
genes in your data set it also searches
for multiple sets simultaneously and we
show it outperforms other methods on
simulated and real data and so I'm going
to start with statistical score by
giving you some motivation so here I'm
showing two different sets of size 3
from the TCGA glioblastoma data again we
have you know jeans or low size Rose
samples as columns and so they're
actually mutating approximately the same
number of samples and one of the earlier
methods den Drix would actually give
them the exact same weight however
they're kind of different in one key way
which is the top set has maybe the most
common mutation in glioblastoma which is
amplifications in egfr grouped with two
other genes with rare mutations that are
not known to have a role in glioblastoma
and the bottom set has three genes
mutated all at more moderate frequency
but that are all involved in in cancer
in glioblastoma and the key thing to
note is that there are many sets such as
this one where we have this most
frequently mutated gene or one of the
most frequently mutated genes grouped
with relatively rare mutations and so we
need actually a way to distinguish these
two sets so we can identify these sets
that we think are more likely to be
involved in cancer because they're a
moderate frequency and so in fact what
we want to do is compute the surprise of
the mutual exclusivity conditioned on
the mutations frequency and so if we add
a pair of jeans we could cross classify
all the
murs based up for the mutated not at all
in the pair of jeans mutating one or the
other or both and we could use one sided
Fisher's exact test for independence to
compute the surprise of the observed
exclusivity so it hasn't been addressed
before is how to score a combination of
more than two genes conditioning on the
mutations frequency and so say we're
looking at a triple three pairs are
three genes you could create a two by
two by two contingency table where we
have these two contingency tables and
now we have this additional dimension
that's based on whether gene 3 is
mutated or not and so then we can you
know go and look and see if there's an
association between the exclusive
mutations across the genes however in
this case there are four degrees of
freedoms meaning there are many ways of
non independence which wasn't the case
when we looked at a pair and so we're
going to do is use a test statistic T
which is the sum of the exclusive
entries of the contingency table and so
with comment we have this algorithm for
computing the tail probability of tea
for arbitrarily size gene sets so to the
K contingency tables and that's how
we're going to compute our you know
mutual exclusivity score however
computing the tail probability can be
expensive in particular what we're
trying to do is given our observed value
of T we need to know enumerate all
contingency tables in the tail that have
as much or more exclusivity and sum up
their masses the only can the condition
on these these tables we want to
enumerate is that they have to have
fixed margins which comes from our
conditioning on the mutations frequency
and this can become quickly becomes
expensive so here I'm showing you a
figure from Saltzman at all where they
plot the number of tables of a certain
size for different dimensional two to
the K tables as sample size increases so
it grows exponentially and while there's
been previous work looking at our by C
contingency tables these are
two-dimensional so not as much has been
done for 2 to the K tables and so we
have with comment is an algorithm to
enumerate only the tables in the tail
and we'll use this based on our
application to kind of deal with the
size of the computation and so in our
application remember we're looking for
exclusive sets of mutations and so you
know in the case where the the mutations
are perfectly exclusive we actually
have no tables to enumerate and can
compute the exact p-value and in
constant time in the case where we have
approximately exclusive mutations well
they're not going to be that many more
tables in the tail so we don't have to
enumerate that much and in the cases
that were you know least interested the
less exclusive sets of mutations we can
actually use a binomial or mutational
approximation because we don't care as
much about the precision of the p value
in that case so it's kind of a whirlwind
tour of the comments otisco score I'm
next going to describe how we search for
multiple sets of exclusive alterations
simultaneously and so the reason we're
looking for multiple sets is because we
all know patients have alterations in
multiple pathways and it's some of our
earlier work on the multi dentrix
algorithm we showed that there are
advantages for searching for multiple
sets simultaneously rather than
iteratively however we do not know the
number or size of the pathways a priori
and they're often many sub optimal
solutions that differed just by one or a
handful of genes and so we're going to
do is going to deal with these these
problems by computing the marginal
probability of observing a pair of jeans
in the same exclusive set so for example
if we were looking at sets of sour two
sets of size three so each of these rows
contains two sets of size three maybe
our true set you know the true pathway
is gene one g2 g3 and g4 and g5 is
colored here but if we're looking for
three genes you might have this third
gene the kind of differs between each of
the top sets and so even though the
values you know the combined statistical
score doesn't change that much just
because you're swapping out this third
gene because you didn't know how to set
the parameter correctly and so we can
actually summarize that in a marginal
probability graph so you can see every
time we sample g1 g2 and g3 together and
also gene for engine 5 together and
that's exactly what comment does it
outputs the high weight sub graphs of
this marginal probability graph and so
we compute the marginal probability
graph using an mcmc algorithm to sample
T sets of size K and proportion to their
combined score and this kind of lets us
test fewer parameters and you need
instead of testing all the parameters
for you know whatever size sets you're
looking for
and so we compared a comment to multi
dentrix in mutex mu X on simulated data
and show it outperforms these these
methods in the paper I don't have time
to go into it today we also an
application to TCGA glioblastoma breast
cancer leukemia and stomach cancer data
sets I want to focus on the glioblastoma
and breast cancer results and so here
I'm showing you two of the top four sets
of size four found by comment on the
TCGA glioblastoma data which includes
around 400 mutated genes in 261 samples
and so you can see that the mutations
are you know highly exclusive this is
the p value of the exact tests for both
of them are you know very significant
they're also mutated in ninety percent
and fifty-five percent of the samples
respectively and so we actually went
back and looked at the corresponding
TCGA paper so you've seen this figure
before but here we actually recovered
the top set is overlapping for the genes
in the RV signaling pathway and this
bottom set is overlapping three of the
genes in the p53 signaling pathway so
this is good but it's not it's actually
not the whole story because if you go
and look at the marginal probability
graph which again I'm showing over here
you can uncover additional structure in
the data and so again these edges
between nodes and the marginal
probability graph are telling you how
often they're likely to the nodes are
going to be sampled together and it's
the same exclusive set and you can see
that we look at the marginal probability
graph we recover an additional gene CD
can't you see in the RB signaling
pathway and perhaps more interesting ly
we find cdkn2a it's kind of between the
RV signaling set and the and the p53
signaling set and so that actually
matches up with the figure from the
paper or CD can see--we is in both and
if you go back and look at the paper it
actually describes have different splice
variants of cdkn2a are involved in these
two pathways and so we actually in the
paper described this kind of hypothesis
for how their alternative ways for these
two pathways to be perturbed but I don't
have time to kind of go into the details
and so the other module identified by
comet is over here highlighting some of
the genes identified that overlap the
pi3k signaling pathway and the GBM paper
and also includes some other well-known
cancer genes
so I want to you know pause here and
emphasize that all of these
relationships were recovered solely by
looking at the pattern of mutation so
solely by looking for exclusive mutation
so there's no notion of interactions or
anything like that in puts a comment and
so I want to conclude by telling you one
more kind of vignette about side that
identifying subtype specific mutations
and I a mutually exclusive mutation
simultaneously so he's already already
heard about this morning kind of
well-known you can cluster samples by
their gene expression so I'm showing a
figure from 2003 where they clustered
breast cancer samples into these five
different subtypes and then later TCGA
and their paper identified mutations
that are kind of associated with
particular subtypes and this can
confound our analysis because this gives
another reason for why genes may have
mutually exclusive mutations they might
just be mutated in one subtype around
the other rather than being in the same
pathway and so with comment we actually
allow you to do simultaneous analysis of
exclusive and subtype specific
alterations and so we have this kind of
input to comment is this gene by patient
matrix where we're marking which genes
are mutated in which patients and if you
know the subtypes in advance we actually
can let you add subtype events that are
mutated in all samples except those of
that particular subtype and so the
reason we do it you know kind of the not
of the of the subtype is because then
when comment identifies an exclusive set
that includes a subtype event you can
see these for these three genes are
largely exclusive with the subtype you
know the red subtype event and that
means almost all other mutations are
occurring in that subtype and so we kind
of let you do both subtype association
and its exclusivity analysis
simultaneously and so we ran comment on
the TCGA breast cancer data set which
includes four subtypes and here's the
marginal probability graph output and so
this the rectangles are representing
subtypes so the lines connecting jeans
to the rectangles are showing a subtype
association while the nodes the the
circles themselves represent genes you
can see we recover parts of the pi3k
signaling pathway as well as this kind
of association between pik3ca and
luminal a that's well known as well as
the well-known herbs
you and her to enriched or pop3 and
basil like associations that's a lot of
time for I want to acknowledge the
co-authors in the paper my advisor Ben
Raphael fabia bundinha and since I will
as well as the research group I'm part
of and my funding dia thank you before I
everyone maybe this can be a discussion
item for the afternoon but i'd like to
ask an immediate question and which may
create some discussion so how do you see
absolutely i got i don't remember
terminology absolutely mutually a mutual
exclusivity and among the ones in which
there's almost mutual exclusivity i
wonder if there's a correlation between
how often you see the two two genes
mutated together and the stage of cancer
yeah so i think i mean in all the
results i showed today there's not
perfect mutual exclusivity it's
approximate and yet we haven't gone and
tried to do the association with stage
but i think it's one of the things in
terms of timing like Nico talked about
yesterday i watch why not three why up
for is it i mean our army is it that
fashion segment or is it is it really
some biological process that we're
capturing and I'd like to discuss I'd
like to hear not that I know people's
ideas maybe in the afternoon it's great
point in the afternoon oh cuz i will
also be talking about on the don't
airspace so okay maybe we can lead it to
thursday because that you know there's
some underlying processes of course they
seems to overlap you're on no doubt i'm
you observe it in our independent
totally different studies but i'd like
to get your opinion yeah so scheduling
wise we we have some more exclusively
thoughts on thursday so might be good
day to do that's a sketch perfect we
have a lot of evolution talks tomorrow
so i was too
picturing that we might have a
discussion on to revolution tomorrow
this afternoon is still a little bit
unknown so anyone that was to propose a
discussion topic for this afternoon with
luck spirit and we have that our so I
can we have a lot of the experts in the
room here on these different topics be
great to have you know some
conversations that are maybe a little
more structured in the afternoon in
addition to all the discussions we're
having over the breaks and over lunch
and one-on-one and in small groups so
you have any thoughts about this
afternoon you know please let Jang car
or myself know and we can add that to
the discussion thank you so you're free
on till two